welcome to marry kill today Ashley will
be choosing from the rest of the
BuzzFeed violet you do to cast Ashley
are you ready to play the game no but
I'm gonna do it for you Internet great
let's get started
ideally I'm Mary Sarah with ax and kill
Ella but I don't think that's gonna I
think it would be best it actually kills
me in this situation I don't want to say
because my mom is probably watching this
I would probably like to be back I would
like to be not killed that's all why do
you go ahead and ask all of our contests
is the first question contestants in
your opinion what does fiance's best
song and let's start with contestant
number one any reason why alright okay
contestant number two same question in
your opinion what is Beyonce's best song
best song I'm going to say halo it's
uplifting it's romantic it's a classic
and contestant number three same
question when she says stuff like run
away it's really you do you let's say
contestant number three would you do her
I would do her she believes in female
empowerment alright let's move on to
round two and round two you're gonna ask
each person a specific question so who
do you want to ask this question to
contestant number two yeah
if you found out you died tomorrow how
would you spend your last day I probably
would spend it just talking to everyone
important in my life you know thinking
about all the important times maybe I
did with a nice dinner of my favorite
[Music]
for sure for sure merits of materials
okay
contestant number three if we were two
scoops of ice cream what flavors would
we be in why chuckling we don't like the
same music so okay interesting
let's ask contestant number one the
final question in this round contestant
number one what is your favorite kind of
bug and why okay interesting we're gonna
move on to Round three this is once
again one question for everybody okay
all contestants please sing a short song
about me let's start with number okay
let's go contestant number two like the
sands of time
Ashley's like a butterfly like a flame
licking on a cold dark night Ashley her
spirit takes flight all right let's hear
the last song from contestant number
three it was beautiful and weirdly
informative I like at the end posed the
question that it quickly answered so
right now I want you to think think back
of all these answers out of number one
number two and number three who are you
gonna are you gonna marry who get a kill
okay all right well what we're gonna do
now we're gonna have all of these people
get set and you're gonna reveal your
answers one by one you ready okay I hope
I didn't okay Ashley now is the time to
find out who you chose to find okay like
a band-aid very happy with this cool
pajamas are those silk jab right one
thank you
no no unfortunately I have to be the
bearer of bad news and show you who you
decided to kill oh my god please not
Sara my Quinta you killed me Sara please
are mosquitoes really your favorite
animal no I think all you like the worst
things like a possible okay thank God I
thought the healthier mosquito wait that
means that I married Sarah it does let's
get to the wedding yay and do you Ashley
take Sarah to be your wife
sure great you guys want to do this just
Europeans Wow yeah well we'll see you
next time on watch music ooh we're done
here by everybody
so you strung me along this whole time
we were just trying to help you
we're in love she doesn't want to date a
liar does she Davis so you've been lying
right to my face yes the launch of the
elevator your salons in the elevator
you're mad at jay-z you're mad dense
where'd you get the haircut Supercuts
yeah you like Daniel no I don't yes you
do you're embarrassing your son almost
ruined our friendship
[Applause]